♪
[Cheers and applause ]
>> Dean Chun: Mr. President, Mr.
Provost, Madame Secretary,
deans, college heads, college
deans, colleagues, friends,
families, and, most of all,
members of the Class of 2022,
welcome to this day, and
congratulations.
[Cheers and applause ]
I now call on the University
Chaplain.
[ Laughter ]
>> Chaplain Kugler: On this
With deep gratitude for this
land on which we stand, my
beloved Yale family, I invite
you to join me in the spirit of
prayer. And the ma JESty of this
life moment, we your beloved
children of creeds, generation,
stories and tongues are gathered
in this place as one human
family united in jubilant
celebration. We're thrilled with
gratitude for our families,
friends, teachers and guides.
Their arms have sheltered us,
their shoulders have boosted us
and today, their hearts soar for
us. Eternal God, it is you who
calls us to our full humanity.
As we celebrate our
accomplishments, we are humbled
and overwhelmed by what life
ahead we live in a world fraught
with heartache and our time at
Yale has been a blend of loss,
uncertainty, discovery and
reconnection. Steady us so that
we may find ways to caress the
beauty of your creation and let
our souls know true delight as
we awaken to the wonder and
mystery of our own unfolding
lives. Through the unity of mind
and spirit, hold us ever close
as we seek to leaven your world
wisely in the steadfast pursuit
of your light and your truth.
For this we say, amen. Now you
may be seated.
>> That which pervades earth,
sky and heaven which is worthy
of worship that has no
beginning, that which is the
light of wisdom and truth, let
us meditate on the radiance of
that divinity. May that
brilliant help inspire and
illuminate our minds, that one
which represents water, light,
and is the quintessence in all
things. May that Almighty
experience pervading the earth,
atmosphere and heaven bless us
with enlightenment.
>> Send forth your light and
your truth. They will lead me.
They will bring me to your holy
mountain, to your dwelling
place, that it may come to the
altar of God, God, my delight,
my joy, that I may praise you
with the higher power, oh, God,
my God. You are the light of the
world. A city built on a hill
cannot be hid. No one after
lighting a lamp puts it under
the bushel basket but on the
lamp stand and it gives light to
all in the house. In the same
way that your light shine before
others. So that they may see
your good works and give glory
to your God in heaven.
[ Cheers and applause ]
>> God is the light of the
heavens and earth. The likeness
of his light is that of a che,
in which there is a lamp. The
lamp is in a glass. The glass is
as it were a brilliant star. Lit
from a blessed tree, an olive
tree, neither of the east norof
the west whose oil seems to glow
even though no fire has touched
it.
Light upon light. God guides
whom he wills to his light. God
makes parables for humanity. And
God has knowledge of everything.
♪
♪ All your works with joy
surround you
Earth and heaven reflect
your rays ♪
♪ Stars and angels sing around
you
Center of unbroken praise ♪
♪ Field and forest, vale and
mountain ♪
♪ Chanting bird and flowing
fountain
Praising you eternally ♪
♪
>> Chaplain Kugler: On this
occasion, it is customary for
the president to deliver a
baccalaureate address and for
the dean of Yale College to
offer readings.
Today we celebrate your journey
through Yale, not the end of
your time here, but instead the
beginning -- the commencement --
ahead.  The love of learning
that you cultivated here will
light your paths forward for a
lifetime. That love of learning
can lead you in any direction
you want - to service, to
scholarship, to leadership - it
might also lead you to
happiness, and in fact you may
have discovered that learning is
itself a form of happiness.
One of the happiest people who
helped you while you were here
may be unknown to many of you:
David Swensen, Yale's chief
investment officer, who died
earlier this year, was deeply
involved in supporng t
university's mission, and he was
a devoted mentor to students.
Here is what he would often say
about them when he talked about
supporting Yale's mission: “I
love the idea that
undergraduates have this
opportunity to study whatever
they want. Students will say to
me, ‘What do I need to take to
be attractive to an investment
bank?' I say: ‘Don't do that.
Take great classes that you
like.' “ Who were the teachers
who changed how you think about
the world and yourself? What
were your happiest activities,
and who were the people who
shared them with you?  I hope
that you know exactly who these
people are, and that you have
thanked them.
In and out of the classroom,
with these teachers, mentors,
and friends, think about all the
ways you have practiced being
happy every day. UC Professor
Sonja Lyubormirsky studies
positive psychology and
happiness. Here she is, as
though speaking to you now: “The
face of happiness may be someone
who is intensely curious and
enthusiastic about learning; it
may be someone who is engrossed
in plans for his next five
years; it may be someone who can
distinguish between the things
that matter and the things that
n't;t mabe someone who
looks forward each night to
reading to her child. In other
words, we all have the potential
to be happy, each in our own
way.” What these activities have
in common is that they help you
be focused in the moment,
something known as flow. Let me
quote Yale's own happiness
scholar and teacher, Professor
Laurie Santos, if I may, eve as
she's sitting up here on stage
as a head of college.
"Challenging activities give us
what positive psychologists call
flow.. the state where we're
feeling really present and
involved and it's kind of hard,
but doable. It's not so easy
that it's boring. And research
suggests that flow states feel
really good."  Author Shawn
Achor, who also studies
happiness, offers similar
advice: “Happiness is a mindset
for your journey, not the result
of your destination  Waiting to
be happy limits our brain's
potential for success, whereas
cultivating positive brains
makes us more motivated,
efficient, resilient, creative,
and productive, which drives
performance upward  The way we
define happiness is the joy you
feel striving toward your
potential.” The commencement
ahead you in fact have long
begun, maybe even before you
arrived here, letting the love
of learning guide you.
My final reading comes from John
Milton, who famously described
some young people you might
recognize, and who, like you,
found themselves taking their
first steps into a new world
beyond the one they knew and
loved.  As you take your own
first steps, I offer him to you
now, from his Paradise Lost:
Some natal trs ty dropp'd,
but wip'd them soon; The World
was all before them, where to
choose Their place of rest, and
Providence their guide:
They hand in hand with wand'ring
steps and slow, Through Eden
took their solitary way.
Congratulations, Class of 2022.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪
♪  ♪
[Singing Alleluia ]
♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Graduates of the Class of 2022,
family members, friends, and
colleagues. It is a special
pleasure to be here with you
Before I get started, I want to
mention this is the last b
baccalaureate at least in his
present role for your dean,
Marvin Chun before he returns to
the faculty. And I'm wondering
if we could all show him a
little bit of gratitude for his
service the last five years.
[ Cheers and applause ]
He's not going far away. So, it
is a special pleasure to be here
with you today.
today, a day made doubly
meaningful by our ability to
celebrate our graduates in
person. I am delighted to
welcome you to Yale's first
on-campus Baccalaureate ceremony
since the start of the COVID-19
pandemic.
[ Applause ]
And after a three-year hiatus,
there is a wonderful Yale
tradition that I would now like
to reinstitute:
May I ask all the families and
friends here today to rise and
recognize the outstanding━and
graduating━members of the Class
of 2022?
[ Applause ]
And now, may I ask the Class of
2022 to consider all those who
have supported your arrival at
this milestone, and to please
rise and recognize them?
[ Applause ]
Thank you!
Our excitement today is
tempered by global turbulence.
We can see the perils of
conflict and crisis around the
world. Yet, as I look out onto
this courtyard, I also can see
the promise of those well
prepared to better our
collective future. Old Campus is
filled anew with the boundless
potential of graduates who offer
cause for hope.
Throughout the country on this
weekend and those weekends
surrounding it, presidents of
colleges and universities are
inspiring their graduating
seniors by telling them that
have received the very best
education possible, and that as
educated adults they are now
ready to go out and make the
world a better place. This is,
of course, true in many
respects, and I have certainly
spoken on other Commencement
weekends of the importance of
improving the world for this and
future generations.
But I would like you, graduating
seniors from Yale College, to
depart from this place with a
somewhat different mindset. I am
going to urge you to recognize
that your excellent education
allows you to listen to others
carefully, consider what they
have to say, and sometimes come
to a new point of view. I am
suggesting today━a day filled
with pride of accomplishment━to
recognize, at the same time, the
value of intellectual humility.
Today, I wish to focus on the
courage to acknowledge all we do
not know, to admit when we are
wrong, and to change our minds.
Sixty years ago, President John
F. Kennedy spoke to a capacity
audience seated right where you
are now. He saw a similar state
of unrest as the specter of war
loomed. And I suspect he gained
a similar sense of optimism atop
this platform from members of
the Class of 1962. President
Kennedy's historic Commencement
address at Yale was sweeping in
its rhetoric and in its scope.
And more than a half-century
later, there is still much for
us to heed from his message,
including the abiding but now
especially relevant value of
seeking new perspectives.
“Too often,” President Kennedy
told the graduates in a rousing
appeal for intellectual
humility, “we subject all facts
to a prefabricated set of
interpretations.” Too often, he
continued, “we enjoy the comfort
of opinion without the
discomfort of thought.” History
teaches us the grave hazard of
certitude and the hubris from
which it germinates.
When I was a graduate student
here, Professor Irving Janis, a
social psychologist, was one of
my teachers. He formulated the
concept of groupthink and linked
the suppression of dissent to a
series of foreign policy
debacles such as the escalation
of the Vietnam War and the Bay
of Pigs invasion.
The Bay of Pigs invasion━a
decision by Kennedy to have the
CIA lead a group of armed Cuban
exiles in a failed attempt to
overthrow Fidel Castro━was
scrid byennedy aide Arthur
Schlesinger as rooted in a
“curious atmosphere of assumed
consensus, [in which] not one
spoke against it.” And as
President Kennedy himself
disclosed to TIME magazine,
“there were 50 or so of us,
presumably the most experienced
and smartest people we could
get, to plan such an operation.
Most of us thought it would
work I wasn't aware of any great
opposition.” Yet “en wsaw
the wide range of the failures”"
Kennedy continued, “we asked
ourselves why it had not been
apparent to somebody from the
start. I guess you get walled
off from reality when you want
something to succeed too much.”
The invasion was an
embarrassment to the United
States, and in those Cold War
days, it pushed Cuba closer to
the Soviet Union.
In the many years since
Present,
the silos in which unchecked
opinion can find refuge have
become both ubiquitous and more
easily accessed; they act as
echo chambers that reaffirm
beliefs in real-time. Within
these silos, speculation travels
great distances without
scrutiny. And the spirit of
discord between these silos
discourages the honest exchange
of ideas across them. In short,
clinging to our circles of
consensus has grown more
comforting━and questioning them,
more difficult.
I encourage you to reject that
comfort, because a willingness
to explore new ideas is what
makes all the difference. You
know this perfectly well, I
realize. The diversity of
academic experiences available
here at Yale ensured that you
were not limited to learning
from those who already shared
your outlook. Indeed, President
Kennedy chose to speak of such
matters at Yale “because of the
self-evident truth that a great
university is always enlisted
against the spread of illusion
and on the side of reality.”
Another social psychologist,
Mark Leary, who recently retired
from the faculty of Duke
University, closely examined the
intellectual humility I seek to
nurture in higher education
generally and in you today. His
review of this attribute━a
recognition that “one's beliefs
and opinions might be
incorrect”━reveals that it is
associated with gratitude,
altruism, empathy, and more
satisfying relationships. And
intellectually humble people are
more likely to be forgiven by
others for their mistakes.
As extremism, polarization, and
resulting gridlock plague our
politics at a time when pressing
challenges call on us to harness
our shared humanity, Professor
Leary details equally
substantial advantages of
intellectual humility for
society, including “lower
acrimony that is based on
differences in beliefs and
ideology [and] greater
negotiation and compromise.”
When we first met four years ago
in Woolsey Hall, I described a
series of obligations that would
accompany your Yale education,
including the responsibility to
be constantly curious━and to
listen carefully to others. At
that 2018 Opening Assembly, I
encouraged members of this class
to remember that “you have come
to Yale because you don't know
everything━not yet.” Now, even
as you prepare to depart Yale
four years later, I will again
declare that your acquisition of
knowledge is unfinished. You
will leave Yale despite not
knowing everything. The
transformative power of a
liberal education lies not in a
promise to teach you everything
but in the preparedness to meet
presumptions━including those we
harbor ourselves━with a healthy
measure of doubt. It lies not in
the ability to answer but in the
audacity to question.
As graduates, it behooves you to
carry forth the inquisitive
attitude you have forged here at
Yale into the world; to carry
forth your insistence on pushing
opinions━including your
own━beyond the confines of
comfort; your resolve to
strengthen your reasoning
through personal investigation
and civil discourse.
In thinking of these trademarks
of the academic enterprise, I am
reminded of a dictum from Rabbi
Moses ben Maimon, the great
medieval philosopher known as
Maimonides. In his introduction
to Pirkei Avot, Ethics of our
Fathers, Maimonides urges
readers to “accept the truth
from whoever speaks it.” Indeed,
wisdom is rooted in this
willingness━this
responsibility━to entertain
ideas brought to you by others.
To listen carefully. To think
critically. To challenge your
views━and then to change them
when the discovery of truth
demands it. As Justice Sonya
Sotomayor said recently, “It is,
I fear, too easy for people to
fail to listen when what they're
hearing is different than what
they think.
As we know, engaging with those
who hold profoundly different
perspectives threatens not to
betray our beliefs, but to
broaden them. Listening to that
with which we may disagree is an
act not of conciliation, but of
fidelity to truth. And admitting
what we got wrong is no sign of
failure, but a necessary step
toward knowledge.
The mark of a great education
consists not only of the new
frontiers of knowledge we reach,
but of thexistg vipoints
we reconsider; not necessarily
of the understanding we gain,
but of the assumptions we shed.
For only when we subject the
“prefabricated set of
interpretations” President
Kennedy spoke of here at Yale to
scrutiny, can we elevate our
limitations into points of
strength. Indeed, humility━that
willingness to say we are
wrong━enables us to scale
otherwise unattainable heights
in the lifelong pursuit of
knowledge.
As Yale graduates, you are
allegiant to truth. You know
that breakthroughs are
byproducts of the questions you
raise, the conventions you
dispute, the fallacies you
uncover. But, also, the mistakes
you own. You know that the “new
ideas and solutions” I spoke of
when we first assembled as a
class four years ago━ideas and
solutions to fight disease,
alleviate suffering, and find
justice━are made better when
they endure the rigors of
critical inquiry.
Perhaps now more than ever, the
world into which you will soon
enter needs you to search for
these solutions. It needs your
expertise. But it also needs
your example as a graduate of
this inspiring learning
environment. It needs you to
continue probing the
preconceptions held by others
and, with equal vigor, those you
hold yourself. It needs your
answers and your questions. It
needs your scholarship and your
skepticism. It needs your
intellectual prowess. And it
needs your intellectual
humility.
It needs you, Class of 2022.
Congratulations.
[ Applause ]
♪
>> May God bless you and keep
you, may the holy one cause
light to shine upon you and
grant you peace. And let us say,
Amen.
♪
[ Applause ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪
[ Cheers and aP plaza ]
[Cheers and applause ]
♪